اثنين اسود وداما اجبر موسكو على الاعلان
عن حصيله هجوم او مجزره مكيفكه غير
المسبوقه منذ بدء الحرب او العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا لم يسبق ان ابلغ
الجيش الروسي الذي نادرا ما يعطي ارقاما
او احصائيات عن عدد القتلى والجرحى في
صفوفه
اربعه صواريخ هاي مارس ضربت مركزا في شهر
مؤقت للجيش الروسي في مدينه مكيفك الواقعه
شرق دنياك التي تحتلها القوات الروسيه
روسيه تعتبر انها ضمتها وهي بالنسبه الى
اوكرانيا
ضرب النظام
امريكيه الصنع مركزه تجمع الوحدات القوات
المسلحه الروسيه قرب مستوطنه في جمهوريه
المسك الشعبيه اسقطت انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه صاروخين من نوعه مارس ونتيجه
لتدمير مركز التجمع باربعه الصواريخ براس
حربي شديد انفجار قتل 63 جنديا روسيا
وسيتم تقديم كل المساعده
لاقارب واصدقاء الجنود الذين سقطوا
لكن كيف حدث الهجوم وكيف استطاعت القوات
الاوكرانيه تحديدا هدفها بدقائق الجواب
نقلته وكاله الانباء الروسيه تاس قائله
تمت الضربه بعد ان سمح استخدام الجنود
الذين وصلوا للتو
استخدامها هواتفهم المحموله بكثافه للجيش
الاوكراني بتحديد موقعهم الجغرافي
استخدامهم للهواتف للجيش الاوكراني بتحديد
موقعهم هذه الحادثه اعددنا الى بدايه حرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا صدرت وقتها تقارير
تحديدا بدايه من شهر مارس الماضي حول
اعتماد القوات الروسيه بشكل متكرر ومفاجئ
على اجهزه اتصال غير امنه كالهواتف الذكيه
واجهزه الراديو التي تعمل بنظام الضغط
للتحدث ما ترك الوحدات عرضه للاستهداف بعد
شهر من الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا صحيفه
واشنطن بوستا نقلت عن مسؤول امريكي ان
الروس سيستخدمون الكثير من الاتصالات غير
السريه وان الاتصالات السريه ليست قويه
كما ينبغي لها ان تكون
الاخطر من ذلك كله ما نقله محللون عن ان
عمليات البث العسكريه الروسيه عبر خطوط
غير امنه منتشره لدرجه انه هواه الراديو
قد يستمعون اليها عبر الانترنت باستخدام
مواقع مثل ويب اس دي ار حادثه اليوم
تذكرنا بحادث مشابهه وقعت في مارس الماضي
قتل فيها جنرال روسي بغاره جويه بعد ان
اكتشفه الاوكرانيون عبر هاتفه المحمول
وفي حاله اخرى شاركتها وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه سابقا سمع اثنان من مسؤولين
استخبارات الروسيه وهما يناقشان على نطاق
واسع وفت ضابط كبير وعندما طلب احدهم
التحدث على خط مشفر قال الاخر انه لا يعمل
[موسيقى]